[Musik]
ein wunderschön und abends um viertel
nach acht dem topf der schlagzeilen
macht heute mit themen die deutschland
bewegen es geht um krieg es geht ums
impfen und es geht um zensur ich habe
wunderbare gäste franziska brantner juli
chef horst merz aus leipzig lisa fitz
kabarettistin und new york ist unser
star -kolumnist beginnen möchte ich mit
einem weiteren gast denn mich hat bewegt
wie heute wladimir klitschko ist
schwergewichts weltmeister der mit
seinem bruder in kiew ist bei vitali
klitschko dort auch wohnt und heute hat
er offiziell gemacht dass wenn russland
angreifen wenn wladimir putin seine
truppen schickt hier sehen wir die
bilder hat er offiziell unterschrieben
dass er dann an die front gehen würde
also bloody mir klitschko steht bereit
sein land zu verteidigen gegen russische
truppen und das besondere hier heute
abend führte nach acht uns ist er jetzt
live zugeschaltet und ich möchte von
wladimir klitschko hören was ihn bewogen
hat der mann der überall auf der welt
leben könnte aber in kiew ist weil er
sagt ich will mein land verteidigen
wladimir was hat dich da heute zu
bewegen und was bedeutet diese
unterschrift guten abend ich habe mich
heute dass sich
lassen für die die ideale verteidigung
zu stehen im falle eines angriffs auf
die ukraine auf die stadt
intensiv beteiligung ist auch initiiert
wurden
von dem bürgermeister und natürlich die
leute die die dazu stehen eigene land zu
verteidigen unsere wahl zu beteiligen
man die motivation gewesen ist die liebe
für meine stadt ihr für mein land die
ukraine
meine familie war letztendlich meine
tochter geht auch jeden kämpfen die
schule und diese liebe ist nicht zu
stoppen ich glaube dass sich dieses
gefühl mit vielen bürger die in kiew
sind und in die ukraine
im falle ich hoffe dass sie nicht
passieren aber in vahle dass sie
angegriffen werden und
dass wir auf einmal
russischen soldaten und demokratischen
boden haben was ist schon eigentlich
keine überraschung mehr dass das
passiert schon seit 2014 im osten der
ukraine in lugansk und donezk on aktion
von cream
und es kann nicht so weitergehen
letztendlich es geht auch um beteiligung
nicht nur die rechte eine breite
demokratische wand zu haben es ist auch
eine an vier tagen gießen massen für
europa weil ich glaube wenn der ukraine
herrscht wird es nicht nur die ukraine
oder in einem territorium der ukraine
bleiben ich glaube dadurch wird auch
betroffen
wladimir muss ein bisschen mit wie geht
es den menschen in kia für jedes deiner
familie vitali als bürgermeister von
kiew ist den ganzen tag unterwegs auch
um mögliche vorbereitungen zu treffen
falls ein angriff passieren sollte aber
wie erklärt man das auch zum beispiel
deiner tochter der familie was da
momentan passiert und wie würdest du den
deutschen die situation momentan
beschreiben es ist sehr angespannt die
situation
ein kleines beispiel
als man ja doch die geht in die
internationale schule die mitarbeiter
von der schule ist und die
familienmitglieder von geschichtliche
botschaften die botschaften sind
evakuiert worden und zwar plötzlich und
schnell auffallen weil ich die schule zu
vorstellen ich schuldig zu und dann die
schule versucht zu realisieren weil
letztendlich ganzen platz an dem ich
arbeite sie
ausländer und der rest ist halt dann die
ukraine und
es ist das ist schon nicht zu glauben
was gerade in dem land geht weil die
leute sind sehr angespannt es ist keine
reform das ist wahrscheinlich nicht der
fall sein wird sondern wir haben das
schon gelernt 2014
keine geglaubt dass russland die ukraine
und westen wird es ist leider passiert
wie gesagt wir wollen nicht es ist mehr
passieren und deswegen für alle fälle
sollten wir beraten sein und ich
verstehe auch dass die unterstufen von
den westen auch in deutschland kommt
aber es ist nie genug unterstützung ich
weiß dass deutschland eine der lernten
der sich
nunmehr 1 wählenden und schnitt ganz
vorne nach der krisenzeiten die ukraine
unterstützt ich würde mich dafür
bedanken aber wie gesagt es ist nie
genug in diese schwierige zeiten man
muss sich wirklich gedanken machen wie
kann man die politik auch die ganzen
welt verwenden würden nicht nur die
ukraine und wir fangen nicht nur mit der
ukraine aber von den königen dass sein
ist auch an auch mit den frieden
aufzubewahren in europa die mir du hast
da heute ein dokument unterschrieben
will muss landes vorstellen jetzt sagen
die leute die uns zuschauern der
wladimir klitschko dann habe ich die box
kampf gesehen er kann überall auf der
welt leben du hast auch lange in den usa
gelebt
warum sagst du wenn putin angreift mit
diesen waffen wo er ja ganz schnell ganz
viele menschen töten kann willst du
trotzdem kiew die ukraine verteidigen
was kannst du dann tun gehst du dann an
die front wie sieht das aus die frage
stellt sich jeder es gibt natürlich
unterschiedliche meinung dann eine kann
davon weg werden auch die möglichkeit
der an den schreiben sie sich das
gesicht die sich herausforderung zu
zeigen und genau das habe ich mich
entschlossen weil letztendlich die liebe
wie ich schon vorher begonnen habe zu
meinem land meine stadt meine familie
meinen nachbarn
meine tochter wie gesagt das hält mir
hier letztendlich ist es unser land
warum sollte wegen weglaufen und wir
haben schon das gelernte in der
vergangenheit dass wir für unser recht
kämpfen sollten und das ist nicht zu
stoppen wie gesagt wenn man dann von der
idee besessen
diesen freien linken zu führen und nicht
nur berühmt zu sein wladimir bleibt
bitte noch ein bisschen bei uns in der
diskussion ich möchte gerne ohne jörges
fragen oder du bist stark kolumnist
lange im ausland mit allen politikern
gewesen was macht das mit dir wenn du
hörst wladimir klitschko sagt ich bin
bereit hier an der front zu kämpfen ich
bin eigentlich eher als
russlandfreundlich bekannt aber ich muss
sagen wenn ich in seiner position wäre
wenn ich in der ukraine leben würde
würde ich mich ganz genau so verhalten
das ist einfach um das große wort zu
bemühen eine patriotische pflicht sein
land zu verteidigen und dessen menschen
zu verteidigen und die füge hinzu
einen verteidigungskrieg ist ein
gerechter krieg da gibt es gar keine
frage also
er verhält sich patriotisch er flieht
nicht ins ausland nimmt sein geld nicht
mit sondern er bleibt dort und daran
gibt es nichts zu kritisieren sondern
dafür kann man ihm nur gratulieren
franziska bandmann juli chefin natürlich
stark vernetzt in der deutschen politik
was macht das mit ihnen wenn sie da
sehen wladimir klitschko den kennt
wahrscheinlich fast jeder deutsche und
der sagt jetzt der ist bereit im krieg
zu ziehen und wir deutschen sitzen hier
und tu nicht so wirklich was oder ja
also erst mal kann ich mir ist es für
mich gar nicht greifbar das wirklich
keiner zwei flugstunden von hier
entfernt sich menschen entscheiden
müssen ob sie im zweifel eines
angriffskrieges russlands der eventuell
erfolgen könnte und als realistische
option
verstanden wird dass sie sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie in den fernen
krieg ziehen würden auch viele junge
menschen ich bin das unvorstellbar und
ich finde dass wir als deutsche uns die
frage stellen müssen was können wir tun
um die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine zu erhöhen um einen krieg
weniger wahrscheinlich zu machen das ist
ganz konkret die aufgabe von uns
deutschen auch er klitschko eben
angesprochen und 2014 gab es bereits
eine situation in der die frage im raum
stand was passiert mit kiew russland ein
angriff wagen oder nicht und ich glaube
dass wir da uns sehr viel auf diplomatie
verlassen haben und am ende gemerkt
haben es hat nicht gereicht und warum
sagt ihre fdp jetzt nicht ja wir
unterstützen niemand wie vladimir
klitschko jahr wir schicken waffen in
die ukraine defensivwaffen warum hilft
niemand klitschko ich sage lasst ich
sage wir sollten unbedingt sofort
defensivwaffen in die ukraine schicken
wir sollten die ukraine auf jeden fall
unterstützen
wir sollten auch deutlich machen an
russland das nicht nur im fall eines
angriffs sondern auch schon im falle
einer so deutlichen bedrohungen von
einem partner von uns von ukrainern die
ihr land verteidigen wollen dass das
eine absolut schreckliche zustand ist
dass wir sanktionen deshalb auch
verhängen werden ich bin der meinung
dass wir die russische regierung
sanktionieren sollten sie sollte nicht
die zivilbevölkerung da in geiselhaft
nähmen aber wir sollten ganz klar ein
zeichen setzen wer so etwas macht wer
die ukraine so drastisch bedroht der
kann mit deutschland nicht rechnen und
der hat im gegenteil mit sanktionen und
mit ganz klaren defensivwaffen und
botschaften von deutschlands seite zu
rechnen vorfalls wie nehmen sie die
diskussion war sie sind kabarettistin im
tv immer wieder präsent die menschen
kennen sie wenn die deutschen über die
ukraine sprechen dann ist das thema ihn
immer noch fern oder wir nehmen sie das
wahr
das eine war es eigentlich unfassbar ist
das im jahr 2022 mit archaischen
methoden immer noch die
auseinandersetzungen geführt werden
müssen was ich habe ja schon gerne im
jahr 2015 habe ich als eine bühnenfigur
hatte ich dieses olga der antike war uns
gesprochen über russland und
geostrategische und hab dann
aufgedröselt sowas ist geostrategisch
strategie ist wenn du deine gartenzwerge
so aufstellen dass nachbar sich darüber
ärgert dass
man das zurückführen müssen auf alles
was passiert ist deswegen bin ich also
ganz im gegensatz zu jenen die für
waffenlieferungen egal wohin sondern
immer für sämtliche mittel auszuschöpfen
friedlich auseinander setzen auch die
schulden nicht so einseitig zu sehen das
würde jetzt zu weit führen deswegen
halte ich mich dann etwas raus okay wir
wollen auch einmal wurde mit 139
vielleicht das ist ja nicht sind noch
die regierungen sind die menschen es
sind ja die millionen russen sind
millionen deutschen millionen und
katharina und da sind ein paar wenige
die millionen ins verderben führen und
das sollte man meinen kopf traf ich
dachte mir wenn du die diskussion hier
auch verfolgst du bist viel mit
deutschland kontakt natürlich weil du in
hamburg auch noch eine wohnung hast wie
erlebst du das und was genau bräuchte
die ukraine in diesen tagen in diesen
wochen wo könnte deutschland mehr helfen
als bislang
ich glaube schon dass wie gesagt es ist
nie genug unterstützung
auch wenn man schon und wie die waffen
spricht dann sprechen wie die
verteidigungswaffen und nicht auf keinen
fall einen griff also wir sind eine
fröhliche
nation die keine morgen waren
angegriffen hat irgendwo auch eine
geschichte wie er wie gesagt mit unserer
editierung 2017 entschlossen haben
richtung europa richtung westliche
qualitäten westliche demokratie frei
weil wir wissen wie das mit
anderen position lernen auch passierte
und wie komplex das ist wie menschen
auch unter druck werden also ist es
definitiv die wahl die wir
genommen haben um mich viel verstehen
dass auch und dafür muss man auch geld
und wir sind auch bereit dafür zu
kämpfen und das haben ja auch in den
vergangenen jahren gemacht als nation
und zustand wir stehen zusammen und wie
gesagt weiß die unterstützung betrifft
fall macht den verstand weil ich
verstehe das auch was medien dann ganz
oft brainwalking machen und die welt
nicht so wirklich darstellen so genannte
ist ein gutes buch ein sprichwort ein
deutsches sprichwort
jugendfußball
letztendlich noch ein bisschen zeit und
wir werden schon verstehen was
eigentlich passiert immer ganz schnell
schon jetzt es ist nicht ein ein
interner konflikt wir wissen schon das
ganze equipment kommt von russland und
das ganz klar ums konto komisches ding
new york nicht eine frage hier unter den
nägeln an wladimir wenn wir nach vorne
schauen
können sie sich vorstellen dass einer
der beiden klitschko-brüder vitali ist
ja bürgermeister in kiew bei der
nächsten präsidentenwahl antritt denn
nach meinem eindruck ist herr seeh
lenski ja nicht der stärkste präsident
im moment
wissen sie was die präsidentin betrifft
es ist immer und
kritische winkel blickwinkel kann man
natürlich hier die führung machen und
sagen diese kritische zeiten ich werde
jetzt keine präsidenten kritisieren
natürlich es gibt genug was man besser
machen kann absolut aber in diesen
schwierigen zeiten glaube wir statt uns
zu teilen und herrschen wir sollten
schon eine einigung haben manchmal fällt
es uns in europa auch diese einigung und
deswegen meine meinung nach dass europa
oder die westliche welt manchmal schwach
ist kann sie ja franziska brantner juli
chefin wladimir hat hier gerade gesagt
defensivwaffen wenn das richtige frau
beugt man ihn trinkt auch noch etwas
unter den nägeln ja ich bin der meinung
dass wir defensiv waffen liefern sollten
alleine deshalb weil wir im krieg
verhindern müssen die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass ein krieg entsteht durch russland
die vermindern wir indem wir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine
erhöhen deshalb möchte dass an dieser
stelle nochmal betonen und ich möchte
auch ganz konkret sagen dass die
bundesregierung hier eine klare
botschaft senden sollte und sich nicht
ich hab mich es hat mich sehr irritiert
dass die spd extra eine klausur machen
musste um dann herauszugehen mit der
botschaft die aggression gehen wir ganz
klar von russland aus ich denke jeder
der sich informiert der weiß auch schon
im vorfeld einer klausur also da möchte
ich die bundesregierung dazu auffordern
eine ganz klare haltung zu zeigen und zu
sagen wir stehen an der seite der
ukraine das tun wir herzlich dankt klare
worte von der juli chef wladimir
klitschko vielen vielen dank dass du
heute aus kiew und zugeschaltet war ist
und so schwer der team wechselt aber ist
ohne jörges aber tatsächlich ist es so
dass natürlich neben der frage was in
der ukraine passiert uns weiter vor
allem das thema corona und die frage was
mit impfung nicht impfungen ungeimpften
das ja der anfang ist ja gemacht in
bayern und in baden württemberg und
niedersachsen und dem saarland haben
gerichte die 2g regel gekippt
schleswig holstein mit demnächst folgen
und zwar freiwillig nicht auf druck von
gerichten das heißt dort können
ungeimpfte wieder ungehindert in jedem
laden gehen einkaufen wie sie wollen hat
das geschadet
keine spur also wenn man die inzidenz
werte in den vier ländern anguckt hat
sich nichts bewegt nix ist nach oben
gegangen und das ist ja auch kein wunder
ich glaube
es ist natürlich richtig und wichtig
dass der handel befreit wird aber damit
ist es nicht getan wenn also der fdp
vorsitzende christian lindner heute
vorschlägt das 2g im handel bundesweit
abgeschafft werden soll dann ist das
zwar richtig aber es springt zu kurz ich
glaube wir müssen den ungeimpften den
weg zurück ebenen in die gesellschaft
aus der sie jetzt weitgehend
ausgeschlossen sind das heißt sie müssen
auch wieder restaurants und cafés
sport clubs und theater betreten können
und und und das ist ja auch nicht allzu
schwierig in wahrheit denn wir erkennen
doch heute das mit omikron dass die
geimpften so ansteckend sind wie die
ungeimpften das kann man heute einfach
so pauschal sagen die geimpften schützen
sich nur selbst gegen schwere
krankheitsverläufe aber infektiös sind
sie auch also kann man mit dem thema
ganz anders umgeht man muss damit ganz
anders umgehen und
wenn wir uns das super zu bewusstsein
führen dann müssen wir das sagen dass
die
das pauschale ausschließen von
ungeimpften nicht nur zutiefst ungerecht
und unmenschlich ist sondern auch den
zweck verfehlt wenn jetzt die berliner
bürgermeisterin franziska giffey sagt im
notfall würden
auch infizierte in krankenhäusern
eingesetzt als arbeitskräfte infizierte
und gleichzeitig werden gesunde
getestete aber nicht geimpfte
krankenpflegern und krankenpfleger
entlassen dann ist das geradezu
irrwitzig vollkommen nieder selig das
heißt noch nichts anderes als dass
gesunde durch kranke ersetzt werden
sollen das ist heute der stand der
deutschen corona politik und da muss ich
sagen dem müssen wir ein ende bereiten
es muss jetzt einfach
dazu übergegangen wären da kann ich nur
alle zu aufrufen auch die in der
öffentlichkeit ein wort haben
die spaltung der gesellschaft zu
überwinden
die
die verfilmung muss ich schon sagen die
verfilmung von ungeimpften
ist ein schwerer krebs schaden an der
demokratie deshalb sage ich weg mit 2g
und zwar im restlos und überall und im
notfall ein wo es notwendig ist 3g da
sind die geimpften die chinesen und die
1 lasst mich noch einen jagen und rege
gewesen und die
getesteten
gleichberechtigt ich als geimpfter sage
freiheit für die ungeimpften freiheit
für die jungen thorsten mann und wie
nehmen sie das wahr wie mit ungeimpften
umgegangen sind arzt in leipzig das ist
ja auch eine region wo wahrscheinlich
relativ viele ungeimpft sind noch
zumindest prozentual gesehen in
deutschland wie nehmen sie das wahr wie
mit also ich kann dem ganzen erstmal nur
zustimmen dass ich sage ich finde es
erstmal gut dass diese irrsinnige
regelung zwei g2 g + 3g gekippt wurde
ja stimmt es eher traurig dass wir dazu
gerichte brauchen und wir eigentlich als
gesellschaft nicht mehr in der lage sind
mit vernunft an solche themen
heranzugehen denn es ist für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar dass plötzlich ein test
den ich bei einem giften anwender zu
mehr sicherheit führt und denselben text
den ich bei den ungeimpften anwenden
unsicher ist also da eine entscheidung
zu treffen wir machen zwei g2 g +
unterscheiden wir wissen selber alle
dass natürlich jeder der geimpft oder
gepustet ist genauso ansteckend ist im
gegenteil im moment sehe ich bei mir in
der praxis eher dass die meisten die
kommen mit positiven corona fällen
geimpft oder gemustert sind und dass
diese menschen natürlich in der breiten
masse den virus vertrag vertreiben und
andere anstecken bobic sieht schreiben
schon fleißig gelben zettel das gar
nicht glauben
also ich muss vorausschicken ich bin
wirklich ich bin war noch nie im
gegenteil was mir auch gut und es wird
wenn man es möglichst schnell wie noch
keine corona leugnen ich war in 40
ländern der erde und dann muss man
teilweise kommt man gar nicht reden ohne
die ganzen impfungen ich fange jetzt
ganz schrecklich und zwar schrecklich
ich bin auf alle fragen
als corinna noch nicht da war gegen
grippe geimpft geben überhaupt nichts
dagegen aber ich bin auch muss ich dazu
sagen und deswegen kann jeder bestätigen
der mich kennt eine lupenreine
demokraten das heißt ich würde mich
fragen als erstes warum verweigert leute
die informiert hat der gründe und es hat
einfach die runde gemacht da kommen wir
dann nachher auf meinem thema das ist so
viel
gordon opfer der impfschäden gibt
vermutlich vermutlich gibt also
verdachtsfälle auf todesfälle im schaden
und es würde zum beispiel wenn sie einen
vermummten käse haben und dann wird er
sofort aus dem markt gezogen da wird der
ganze konzern dicht gemacht wenn sie im
wurm im fleisch oder irgendwas haben
sofort ein riesen geschneidert die ganze
presse und oder wenn sie wenn nestlé
baby nahrung verteilten sagt in 1500
sind aber glasscherben drin sehr gut
aber mir also würde ich dann durch und
jetzt kommen wir ja nicht das ganze mit
glasscherben zu vergleichen denn wenn
man sich anschaut prozentual gesehen wie
viele menschen sich auf der welt haben
impfen lassen mit verschiedenen
impfstoffen muss man ja sagen dass die
vermeintlichen schäden prozentual sehr
sehr sehr sehr sehr klein richtig aber
würden sie trotzdem sie erwischt wird
schon gut gehen sonnig gerät von den von
den leuten die vorbehalte haben ich bin
auch geimpft also aber ich hab doch
nichts passiert offenbar ich habe mich
auch sehr entfernt gehalten habe mir
angeschaut
die maske aufgesetzt aber ich würde doch
warum der punkt ist doch sehr die leute
die sich nicht impfen lassen haben große
bedenken aus verschiedenen gründen weil
ich die runde gemacht hat und wir sind
wieder fake nach sonst wären also es
gibt durchaus in vielfältigster darauf
jetzt muss man sagen die virtuelle ebene
anschaut wie hat man also warum hören
nicht eingegangen das ist sehr oder also
das höchste darauf eingang also jetzt
muss ich glaub ich hab rcd erfüllst du
dir das nicht immer alle einen
widersprechen muss also diese impfung
ist sehr sehr sicher es wurden 500 600
millionen impfungen verimpft in alleine
in der eu und sie haben ja damals in
einer sendung gesagt es gebe 5000
impfschäden und dann hat sich
herausgestellt dass es da gar keinen
kausalen zusammenhang gab der
nachgewiesen wurde also ich möchte
einmal ganz kurz sagen ich halte es für
eine ethische pflicht jedes einzelnen
sich ganz deutlich damit
auseinanderzusetzen ob man sich nicht
impfen lassen kann um hier gemeinsam
auch als gesellschaft voranzukommen und
ich persönlich kann nur jedem dazu
auffordern gerade die ungeimpften sich
impfen zu lassen gerade denen die auch
keine erstimpfungen hatten ich möchte
dazu auffordern sich bitte impfen zu
lassen weil ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass wir als gesellschaft
also vorankommen so aber am ende ganz
oben
und immer zu ihnen zu ihrer eigenen
these kommen weil sie haben
dabei bleiben richtig gerne wissen
welche möchte ganz konkret wissen von
wir alle zusammen und ethik und lasst
euch doch impfen und warum wo ist die
gefahr dass umgehend das ist doch immer
lässig wenn der genaue haben wenn der
geliebte genauso ansteckendes war wo
liegt sie gefahren in einer gibt
ungeimpfte und getestetes könnte man
kann mit irgend jemandem erklären da
haben wir uns dann verschiedene
begründungen gewöhnt die letzte die wir
gehört haben und die jetzt gängig ist
lautet man wird zwar durch impfen nicht
nicht steril und man steckt andere
durchaus weiter an aber bei einem selbst
ist halt der krankheitsverlauf womöglich
ja weniger stressig wenn man glück hat
muss
aber
das ist jetzt alles so wild
durcheinander übrigens um das wir kommen
ja noch mal drauf bei deiner these es
ist halt auch so wenn die
gesundheitsbehörden in diesem fall das
rk ii robert koch institut eine
vernünftige arbeit machen würden die ich
nicht erkennen kann jetzt werden ja auch
daten geschätzt weil sie gar nicht mehr
nachkommen infizierte und so weiter dann
hätten die natürlich auch mal eine
statistik eröffnet über impfschäden und
dann wäre das dann wäre das transparent
und man wüsste wie viel sind immerhin
gemeldet worden und man könnte einer
einer solchen verdacht entgegentreten
kann man gar nicht gibt es gesicherte
zahlen über impfschäden die gibt's ja
gar dass ich
das ist schon eine spannende these also
die frage dass sozusagen das datenchaos
des zahlen chaos auch dazu führt dass
menschen verunsichert werden weil
dadurch dass es eben keine wirklichen
daten gibt
dazu führt dass möglicherweise telegramm
und überall irgendwelche gerüchte
verbreitet hatten über vermeintliche
impfschäden ich glaube das ist das ein
sehr für uns jetzt in der runde an
diesem punkt einigen können dass es
leider zu viel fett news gibt und so
viele unwahrheiten in umlauf gebracht
werden und deshalb finde ich es ganz
wichtig dass wir ganz klar daten
transparent machen und mit daten
transparenz nach außen gehen und ich
finde gerade wenn man nach dem partner
guckt wo beispielsweise gerade viele
öffnungs schritte getätigt werden was
ich sehr gut finde da wird das ja ganz
konkret auch basierend auf daten gemacht
die vorliegenden echtzeit das ist in
deutschland leider oft nicht der fall
das ist wirklich ein großes problem da
ich glaube das ist ein punkt auf den
konsens einigen bei einem anderen hatte
ich eine anleitung das wundert mich ein
problem ist aber sehen geben wird in die
daten das ist ja das große problem vom
robert-koch-institut kriegen wir jeden
tag tolle statistiken präsentiert aber
ich frage mich ich als arzt als hausarzt
wo kommen diese zahlen her also ich
teste meine patienten dies ist es geht
an ein labor da es keine verknüpfung
dazu ist das jetzt ein geimpft oder
ungeimpfter die patienten werden nicht
vom gesundheitsamt gefragt und trotzdem
erscheinen plötzlich daten beim
robert-koch-institut die sagen sollen
sie fünf prozent sind geimpft und
soundsoviel sind umgehen haben sie denn
man fragt ja sag ich gefragt aber keine
antwort gekriegt das ist ein interessen
problem von menschen die ganz normale
bürger sind die kriegen keine antwort
sie sind ja hart das heißt ja sie in
ihrer praxis wenn jemand zu ihnen kommt
und sich jetzt impfen lassen will ist
das möglich bei ihnen gegen tetanus
diphtherie poliomyelitis jederzeit alles
ich eben für keine
menschen mehr gegen kramm ist das reden
was in anderen impfungen richtig
dazugehört immer eine entsprechende
aufklärung und das ist also auch ein
problem warum es vorbehalte gegen diese
impfung gibt warum ist das so weil ich
ich habe eine zeitlang geimpft und es
kam dann immer mehr patienten zu mir die
ich dann im gespräch gebracht sie wollen
sich heute gegen korona impfen und dann
kam die antwort ach ich will nicht ich
muss mein arbeitgeber und meine familie
und sowas eigentlich will ich mich nicht
impfen und da muss ich sagen das
widerspricht jeglicher ärztlicher ethik
wir können nicht gegen den willen des
patienten eine impfung eine blutentnahme
eine operation ein medikament geben das
ist konsens da gibt's den nürnberger
kodex wo das ganz klar drin steht auch
in buddy die die patienten kamen wir
freiwillig zu ihnen haben dann aber von
dem druck berichtet offenbar genau aber
niemand die hand das bedeutet jetzt ja
nicht dass sie gegen den willen der
patient auch etwas in den rahmen ram
doch ich muss entscheidend ist dass ein
freier wille des patienten oder ist er
unter druck entstanden steht auch so
drinnen im nürnberger kodex können sie
gerne nachlesen und das machen wir uns
immer klar auch bei der aufklärung wie
weit versteht der patient eigentlich was
ich gerade mit dem patienten spreche ich
kann im mediziner laut einer szene und
er nickt das alles ab
sie sagen sie wollen geimpft werden also
ich will jetzt weil ich warte schon so
lange drauf das ist richtig sie mich
bitte richtig dann ich eben wie die
trotzdem nicht weil ich habe oder wir
haben in leipzig genug andere
möglichkeiten und ich kann die patienten
dort auch hin verweisen für mich ist
wichtig diese freiwilligkeit in der
impfung aber wenn jemand freiwillig
kommt dann ein haro zum nein das sage
ich trotzdem auch in einer freiwillig
sein weil ja das mag sein dass er
freiwillig bei mir ist weil ich das aber
nicht mehr vor bewerten kann inwieweit
diese freiwilligkeit ein ausdruck ist
oder ob es doch druck gibt denn viele
kommen wirklich und wir spüren alle den
druck der bevölkerung ist wir haben mit
2g 3g angefangen also wie freiwillig
sind wir denn eigentlich noch in unseren
einen rettungswagen für andere impfungen
wie weit sind wir denn in unseren
entscheidungen
ob ich kann da ich war auch bleiben aber
weil unsere sie haben habe ich nicht
sagen aber sie sprechen ja über diesen
umgang insbesondere bei der frage
abweichender meinung was sie besonders
bewegt als arzt in leipzig und das
interessiert uns was da aus ihrer sicht
momentan passiert ja abweichende meinung
ist man ja immer gleich wenn man sagt
okay ich irgendwie hier nicht oder ich
habe sehe das kritisch wir müssen über
solche dinge sprechen und man wird immer
ganz schnell in eine ecke geschoben ob
das rechtsradikale träge oder ähnliches
ist also wie gesagt ich impfe auf und
diese woche war für mich eine besondere
woche weil ich plötzlich gemerkt hat es
gibt in der gesellschaft etwas
ausspricht ein kleines pflänzchen der
hoffnung ich habe von dem landrat in
bautzen gehört der mit den
spaziergängern am montag gesprochen hat
ich habe von dem oberbürgermeister aus
kamenz gehört der die spaziergänger ins
rathaus eingeladen hat gesagt wir müssen
reden und er hat sich dann am nächsten
wieder vor seinem rathaus gestellt und
eine ganz tolle rede gehalten um genau
diese spaltung zu überwinden wir haben
als gruppe in leipzig ein aufruf
gestartet für mehr toleranz und
mitmenschlichkeit und haben zu einem
runden tisch eingeladen und der ist
letzte woche freitag vonstatten gegangen
wir haben auch das große glück dass wir
den veröffentlicht konnten seit montag
wo es darum geht dass man wirklich mal
in andere gesprächsrunde miteinander
spricht ohne schaum vorm mund ohne dann
immer gleich in eine ecke impfgegner
geschoben zu werden die dinge die fakten
auf den tisch zu bringen und sachlich
vernünftig wie ist einfach gehört in
einer demokratie miteinander umzugehen
wertschätzend ohne beleidigung und
ähnlich ist und warum wir das so wichtig
ist weil ich merke das sind eigentlich
die normalen grundlagen einer demokratie
und ich habe gemerkt das ist nicht mehr
normal was hier gerade passiert ich habe
mich
schön ich habe in meiner ganzen ich weiß
nicht mehr von uns altersmäßig aber ich
habe meiner 40-jährigen mindestens 40
jährigen berufslaufbahn ich habe noch
nie in deutschland erlebt und ich bin am
klavier aber längst den beruf noch nie
erlebt dass abweichende meinungen und
wenn jetzt das wort alt attraktiv sagt
meine nicht alternative für dopfer eine
alternative meinungen zweitmeinungen
dass dies mit solcher vehemenz
diskreditiert und
weg geschoben worden sind denn es gibt
einfach egal wer welche meinung hat und
hier das beste beispiel wir können uns
opposition offen
aber
ich will zunächst mal bevor wir die
verfolgen interessanten punkt weitere
ich muss nochmal darauf zurückkommen auf
meine these zweig muss weg ich das
erwarten dass weniger wissen als
liberale politiker müssen sie nicht nein
wenn man eigentlich spitze kämpften
zurückkehren wir sind jetzt beim thema
meinungsfreiheit irgendwann einmal ganz
schön keine sekunde beim thema
antworten aber würde mir nicht gestattet
na da sowieso nicht glauben da mussten
alle maßnahmen auf das mit sicherheit
prüfen und als zweig eingeführt wurde
war es deutlich sodass man gesehen hat
auf den intensivstationen
weniger platzte es wurden viele
operationen abgesagt für andere
krankheiten zum beispiel weil sehr viele
besonders in sehr hohen maße ungeimpfte
da intensivstation plätze belegt haben
jetzt sehen wir bei dem intensivstation
staton geht es gott sei dank endlich
zurück es geht aber anders jetzt ja den
rollstuhl jetzt trotzdem beim herren
meinungsfreiheit bleiben berben ja das
war der hammer noch sagen was man will
kann man etwa hier auf jeden fall ich
glaube aber wenn man meinung vorträgt
die vom menschen abweichen da muss man
auch widerspruch ertragen und ich bin
etwas überrascht ihr statement feier wir
müssen uns immer toleranz einsetzen aber
ich frage sie wo es ihre toleranz
gegenüber jenen die zu ihnen kommen und
sagen ich habe die freie entscheidung
getroffen ich möchte mich impfen lassen
da müssen sie doch auch tolerant
gegenüber den sein und sagen ich
respektieren sie die freie entscheidung
und ich würde sie im film
respektiere die freie entscheidung
ich vermittle einen termin es gibt
genügend praxen wo sie geimpft werden
können das ist kein problem da dürfen
sie hingehen man muss auch dazu sagen
impfen ist jetzt nicht so wie bei
tetanus also das braucht auch schon ein
bisschen vorbereitung man muss dafür
extra sprechstunde machen um das
ordentlich zu machen um als auch eine
ordentliche aufklärung zu machen und ich
verwehre keinem diese impfung aus sie
kriegen eine beratung ja natürlich für
euch die selber nicht durch das
interessant zu sehen es gibt also nicht
nur menschen die entschlossen sind sich
nicht impfen zu lassen ich habe nicht
den eindruck dass die wesentlich
abnehmen sondern ich habe den eindruck
dass die impfkampagne der
bundesregierung zusammengebrochen ist da
tut sich kaum mehr was das ist alles
erschlafft wieder bundeskanzler auch und
sein gesundheitsminister jetzt gibt es
stellen aber fest es gibt auch ärzte und
menschen medizinischen personal die das
ganz genauso sehen die also auch sagen
ich empfinde ich und ich wahrscheinlich
sagen sie auch ich werde nie impfen das
konnte ich
werde sofort wieder anfangen zu impfen
wenn die impfung eine stellenwert hat
wie eine ganz normale
grippeschutzimpfung wie eine tetanus
impfung wo wirklich diese freiheit da
ist wo ich nicht sagen muss er kommt
jetzt und weiß nicht genau unter welchen
druck
sagen dass ich ja nur deshalb weil sie
ein gutes beispiel dafür sind dass es
solche meinungen der mitte der
gesellschaft auch im medizinischen
apparat gibt und wenn ich das richtig
einschätze sind sie weder rechtsradikal
noch ein verschwörungstheoretiker ich
möchte einmal zuvor feld zurückfällt
eigentlich gab es doch noch nie so viele
möglichkeiten
seine ihre meinung zu sagen nein es gibt
facebook es gibt instagram es gibt
soziale medien das gab es doch früher
alles nicht warum haben sie dann
trotzdem das gefühl sie können ihre
meinung nicht mehr so richtig sein
richtig man kann natürlich die meinung
sagen man muss halt bloß dann aushalten
dass man zum beispiel nicht bei mir sind
ganz konkreter fall nachher aber dass in
anderen berufen dass man das ja eine
stelle gekündigt wird oder dass man als
pfleger nicht mehr ändert dass man dies
nicht darf dann ist man sich sicher
jetzt wird's war damals nichts nichts
radikales auch nichts rechtzeitig oder
linksradikale sondern es gibt viel
zensur bei youtube werden einfach ganze
ding gegen eine versetzung auch
radikales sagen dürfen die
meinungsfreiheit hat kein geländer oder
so ja da muss
unterscheiden muss zwischen
meinungsfreiheit und zwischen falschen
tatsachenbehauptung also ich glaube da
muss man schon eine gewisse
unterscheidung von richtig junge tag und
da würde ich dann gern selber drauf
gekommen sind alles gute leute dass noch
einmal ich glaube viele leute nehmen
sehr schnell das war zum beispiel zensur
in den mund oder ich höre ganz auf zum
beispiel vom thema angeblich hätten wir
keine demokratie oder so und ich finde
das ehrlich gesagt den menschen
gegenüber die wirklichen die wirklich 10
so erfahren wirklich nicht in der
demokratie geben wenn ich das nicht
verlernt sie sagen ist heute baut ist ja
das würde ich mir
ein anderes thema das ist bei anderen
ganz anders
kommen wir gleich drauf was ihnen
persönlich passiert ist er um noch mal
ein bisschen genereller zu bleiben was
erleben sie dabei freunden bei denen die
mit denen sie zu tun haben warum gibt es
die sorge dass etwas passieren könnte
meines ist also nicht bei der impfung
ist aber mein und ganz generell bei der
meinung zu sagen hat bei der freundin
meiner frage ob man noch die mainzer
haben das sagen wohin in meiner
tradition war ich spd und er links fach
so kann ja auch hinlegen oder links von
der spd so ich bin wirklich in gefahr
ich im moment so wird zur afg
überzulaufen sage ich einfach mal laut
aber trotzdem ist die hftl von ein paar
millionen leuten gewählt die sagen
irgendwas sie machen also
heftige opposition die macht ja sonst
keiner mehr weil dies alle weitgehend
einer meinung sind also kann ich nicht
oder demonstrationen ich kann nicht
sagen das sind lauter rechtsradikale
analytisch wurde spinner duschköpfe das
erste was haben unsere zimmer denn sieht
man erst mal den demonstrationen wie
beide unna massen abermals gegen was
auch immer wurde sondern
müssen reden können ich würde persönlich
aus der afc elemente entfernen die
völkischen und und hetzen übrigen ja
gerade erlebt dass ich eben auch
radikalere dort durchgesetzt haben gegen
vermeintlich gemäßigte das haben wir
beim thema mieten und hörte erlebt er
hatte den mann als rechtsradikal
bezeichnen muss sich durchgesetzt ja
aber erneuten hat ihn in die position
gebracht sich durchzusetzen er hat ihn
gefördert er hat ihnen auch gebraucht
eine ganze zeit heute ist der saulus zum
paulus geworden den darf man nicht ernst
aber ich habe immer noch nicht ganz
verstanden einfach wird's was was
passiert dann aus ihrer sicht den
menschen die sich äußern in einer weise
wie es vielleicht der mehrheitsmeinung
ja ganz einfach wenn wenn zum beispiel
einer trainer sagt ich werde ich möchte
mich nicht gerne impfen lassen ich
kennen aus der familie aus der weiteren
verwandtschaft dann kriegt er
schwierigkeiten im beruf wenn einer sagt
ich bin nicht einverstanden mit der
impfpflicht wenn einer sagt ich hätte
ich werde meine politisch dieses an
denen es dann kriegt er schwierigkeiten
als er kriegt sich ob er kriegt die wird
vielleicht gekündigt wird gebeten zu
kündigen schwierigkeiten sorgt könnte
irgendwas das ist das beispiel dafür was
ihnen passiert ist und das was ihnen
beim swr passiert ist darüber sprechen
wir hier nach der werbung
also da kann ich ein lauter frauen nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren sind viertel nach acht geben der
schlagzeilen machen mein name ist wieder
schick
so nicht
zvg aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darm führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russen die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
afg zugegangen lasst den leuten spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatale ist
in der politik bei den journalisten
deren job ist es doch gerade hat bei ihm
meinungen zu führen und sie sollen den
doch auch wichtig sein dass gerade
hinein das konnte zum manko leider
konnte ich das auch
dennoch ist die übliche anorak trainer
ausbilden ich hatte meinen fall um eine
sache immer bekommt er kümmert sich
darum niemand ist
da ganz knapp drüber sprechen ganz
einfach nicht der hat mich richtig ist
die komödie nicht begraben nur noch
vierter noch
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück zu finden
nachdem tochter schlagzeilen macht und
heute charakter richtig krieg impfen
debatten corona meinungsfreiheit und
jetzt ist lisa fitz an der reihe die
sich gecancelt wird
also ich habe am 10 dezember einem
beitrag in der spätschicht comedy bühne
gemacht vom swr mit wenigsten und 80er
jahren zusammenarbeite die redaktion
kann den text hat ihn abgesegnet hat ihn
gesehen so dann komme ich zur
aufzeichnung auf fünf minuten zur
aufzeichnung konfrontiert nichts dass
der moderator schröder damit nicht
einverstanden ist und sagen wird er ist
überhaupt nicht meiner meinung in der
anmoderation das ist erstmalig und
einmalig in der kabarett oder überhaupt
tv-geschichte
dann habe ich das trotzdem gemacht dann
hat ein ist es auffällig geworden der
matthias meißner von der taz hat das
losgetreten anging ein
sturm durch die presse mit schwulen und
lisa fitz und luc wälder die rede war
von 5000 toten das war mittel
unglücklich kann die nachher aber
erläutern wie zuge kommen
dann ging es los und dann hat man die
meinungsfreiheit beim swr verteidigt und
dann hat er programmdirektor clemens
bratzler hat sich unter medialem druck
gefühlt und hat verlautbaren lassen die
zahlen von lisa fitz sind nachweislich
falsch das wissen was aber juristisch
anfechtbar weil er gar keine nachweise
richtigen zahlen liefern kann der swr
bis dato auch nicht dann hat das
eskaliert und unter diesen in die
afghanische rechtsanwalt des prüfen
lassen denn dort alter und werde sagten
ja als es anfechtbar dann stand es im
raum bestellung wurde gespannter und
dann hat die redaktion wir wollten aber
weitermachen und der schluss war dass
die redaktion von sonne ich nenne es mal
als die würden sich das gebiet neuer
quellen schikane für nächsten text
gemacht haben das stimmt nicht und so
geht's nicht und das gibt es nicht und
wir können auch nicht mehr telefonieren
weil der rechtsanwalt hängt im raum wer
gegen platz gegangen und dann habe ich
zwei kinder so kann ich nicht arbeiten
fazit das hätte man anders regeln müssen
und für mich war das ein vertrauensbruch
weil loyalität geht anders jetzt hat der
swr zu ihnen aber gesagt man hätte gerne
mit ihm weitergemacht
es war sozusagen der schritt kam nicht
vom swr aus und bei den zahlen die sie
ansprechen der vorwurf was die
impfschäden oder im toten angeht diese
quelle bezieht sich auf einen man kann
sagen rechts verschwörerischen blog wo
jetzt keine tatsächlich einmal anzusehen
sind das
ist jede 5000 stammen von einer
französischen rechtsextremist hat im
europäischen parlament virginie
ich hab da muss man auch mal schauen wie
die sind die zahlen wieder ranzukommen
das ist ein entschließungsantrag dass
wir vom eu parlament und ich bin
tatsächlich also nicht reingefallen wenn
die entschließung anderen wurde
tatsächlich gestellt von der vision ist
was sie versäumt haben nachzuholen dass
sie wurden der for national ist hat man
mir vorwerfen beträgt musste ich nicht
getan also jetzt die hat aber ihre zahl
von der ma von europäischen
arzneimittelagentur und voller guter
wünsche lenzen ich glaube ich sind teil
davon daher hat sie nicht von
irgendeinem blog wo irgend wer die
impfschäden schreibt sondern daher hat
sie ihre zahlen ich hab dann
recherchieren lassen ich hätte was ich
versäumt habe jetzt sagen ist
verdachtsfälle ja das war aber dass
sowas bespricht man den sender da hat
nicht ganz deutschland kein großer
unterschied verdachtsfälle oder aber
dann hätte man mich geholt fragt was
haben wir da können wir das und so
weiter reden ich mit dem jobverlust
wurde herzlich mich im mittelpunkt
stellen vorher genau das und dann habe
ich es inzwischen auf eigene kosten
recherchieren lassen und zwar vom kck
der aber 20 jahre monitor hat für die
zdf anstalt jahre lang recherchiert und
der hat herausgefunden dass kann ich
kommt demnächst auf meiner webseite
herbst versprochen dass mit hoher und
höchster wahrscheinlichkeit
5000 mindestens tote durch impfschäden
zu beklagen und ziemlich mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit auch große starke
nebenwirkungen und das jetzt nicht so
auf eine auf einem ohr ankommende
recherche das in seine quellen was das
zufällig also wenn man ja ja das sind
diese ganzen dieses robert koch das
thema das sie ja williams ist denn die
ganzen kopf des opfers jetzt wir können
jetzt schwierig über eine reserve noch
nicht veröffentlicht ist deswegen muss
man ganz vorsichtig sein noch bei der
zahl vorsitzende jahres unserer sicht
das ist auch schwierig weil man kommt
wenden wenn sie recherchieren dann
kommen sie auf die 700 der unterseite
von der ehemaligen medizinischen
englischen richard schöne sind wie
schwierig das kennen wir journalisten
frau den brand planung wie nehmen sie
das war die frage wie in da möchte ich
mal darauf zurück das war der ursprung
der debatte in öffentlich-rechtlichen
talkshows in diesem fall oder
kabarettisten sendung damit
unterschiedlichen meinungen umgegangen
wird also wir reden jetzt hier nicht
über unterschiedliche meinung sondern
über sie haben ja sagt das war in dem
fall eine falsche tatsache die sie da
vorgetragen haben und sie hätten sich
dafür gern entschuldigt in
zusammenarbeit mit dem sender so habe
ich das wahrgenommen also ich glaube
dass wir auch grundsätzlich gar nicht
der meinung waren dass ging da jetzt
irgend wie der mund verboten wurde
sondern sie haben ja gesagt man hätte
das im vorfeld klären müssen es hat mir
auch auffallen müssen dass da ein fehler
unterlaufen ist und ich hätte mich dafür
entschuldigt so habe ich jetzt ihre
sendung wurde grenze ja wurde der
ausbildung nach afrika die chance ja
aber in der sendung war als
tatsachenbehauptung deshalb finde ich
grundsätzlich erstmal in ordnung an der
senat zu nehmen und dann haben sie ja
gesagt mediatheken genau in der
bibliothek und dann haben sie ja gesagt
sie möchten in zukunft nicht mehr mit
ihm zusammenarbeiten und jetzt hab ich
mal so ein bisschen recherchiert was
wieso teilweise als kabarettistin so
gesagt haben mal sie haben zum beispiel
gesagt gegenüber von russia today
es ginge um andere kabarettisten seien
systemimmanent hofnarren viele werden in
deutschland einer demokratischen
diktatur der parteien und ich finde wenn
man so krasse sachen sagt dann finde ich
komisch wenn man dann in der kritik
steht dass man dann sagt der sender
hätte mir emotional mehr zur seite
stehen deshalb ich finde wenn man so
krasse aussagen macht dann muss man auch
auf der anderen seite dann wenn man eine
falsche tatsachenbehauptung im raum
gestellt hat muss man dazu stehen muss
man sagen das tut mir leid und ich
entschuldige mich und ich werde auf
meine kleine besser recherchieren ja das
können sie erfinden wenn ich jetzt sagt
frau lehrerin aber ich das ist schon
moralismus den ich nicht annehme wälder
weil da wird der clemens bratzler hat
verteilt zahlen sind nachweislich falsch
und das kann ja nicht sagen das können
sie auch nicht sagen dass gerade niemand
sagen sie sind nicht nachweislich falsch
aber auch nicht nach was ich richtig
muss man nein weil sie sind nicht
nachweislich falsch weil die richtigen
gar nicht nachweisbar sind rechts vor
juristisch angreifbar also hätte wäre
dem bratscher kein zacken aus der krone
gebrochen wenn er mich angerufen werde
sagt fitz können wir neue regeln weil
ganz falsch so falsch dass du unser
fokus hat sich verstiegen frau witz
liegt bewusst sein wir gedacht jetzt
hausherren früh also
gewünscht hätte ich mir dass das da ist
mir auch bei herrn zu chef beim herkommt
sagt was ist da gelaufen das ist nicht
gut dann hätten wir das geredet dann
hätten wir die gemeinsame ohne dass der
selber irgendwas verbreitet war es dann
zum halali praest um mich in ganz
deutschland als lügnerin schmugglerin
unglaubwürdige tante was er zum gar
nicht so stimmt neben mir gemeinsamen
erklärung abgegeben ich bin da einer
tante aufgesessen die mir nichts von der
politik her recht ist und ich möchte
gern wir schneiden den beitrag ich wäre
es anders formulieren ich würde sagen
verdachtsfälle dann hätten wir gemeinsam
die kuh vom eis geholt und gekündigt
habe ich aber noch nicht deswegen
sondern weil dann die arbeit nachdem das
gelaufen ich habe dann gesagt ich mache
nichts
rechtliches ich will nur einfach jetzt
aus weil mir die arbeit dann so
erschwert wurde darin dass er sich aber
da gesagt amazons reich und der begriff
reich ist aber schon belastet das können
wir so nicht sagen und dann haben sie
gesagt chef bessers da dessen reich ist
grenzenlos sie können das besser nicht
unterstellt und dann ging's aber gesagt
jetzt könnte ich muss also ich muss mal
was wir kennen
solange ist mama ich muss ja was mir an
aber du hast einen fehler gemacht du
hast nämlich die 5000 ins spiel gebracht
ohne zu wissen woher sie stammen und sie
stammt doch da wo es auch schon damals
wusstest du doch wusstest du nicht dein
klavier genie schon hoch eine
rechtsextremismus sich so das hast du
dann erkannt und dann hast du gesagt
wenn ich das gewusst hätte hätte ich
nicht immer hat sie jetzt ist nicht
gesagt und dann nachdem du das sozusagen
eingeräumt hat dass ein fehler war hast
du das recherchieren in auftrag gegeben
und jetzt sagst du eben auch jetzt steht
noch nicht fest wie viele in wahrheit an
omikron
corona gestorben center in europa das
heißt du führst ein rennen gegen den
sender das so gar nicht gewinnen kannst
auch nicht gegen die öffentlichkeit
gegen große teile der öffentlichkeit da
musst du einfach sagen wenn ich das
gewusst hätte ich es nicht gemacht hat
sich dagegen habe das zu ändern hat sich
da etwas verändert und sind sozusagen
öffentlich
rechtlichen aber auch insgesamt bei der
es ist ja den weiten teilen was er sagen
wollte mir ist das dreimal passiert bei
öffentlich rechtlichen sendern da habe
ich nicht so was gemacht habe ich nicht
mit zahlen hantiert sondern hat eine
abweichende meinung vertreten was war
das für eine beispielsweise habe ich
gesagt dass ich zweig für
verfassungswidrig halten weil es am
großen teil der menschen nämlich in
umkämpften ihre rechte nimmt und zwar
auf verordnungs basis so das ist gar
kein ja meine meinung sache ist dir dann
passiert also dann bin ich dann bin ich
zweimal ausgeladen worden und einmal ist
ein text von mir verschwunden aber wie
hat man das begründet hat man nicht
anders hat man anders begründet weil ich
als journalist bin da will man sich ja
nicht in die falle begeben mir zu sagen
also einmal ist das thema einer sendung
verändert worden kurz sehr kurzfristig
zum anderen mal hat man mir jetzt sagen
ich mache etwas einfaches waren
kunstvolle formulierung gesagt wenn ich
in die sendung käme um über mein buch zu
reden müsste man ja mit mir eigentlich
auch nach dem was ich jetzt gesagt hätte
über corona reden das sei aber nicht der
gegenstand der sendung und deshalb könne
man mich nicht einladen zu überzeugen
ich hoffe dass ich hätte
das war der sage ich jetzt mal die
einzige ausnahme das war der bayerische
rundfunk eine sehr kuriose geschichte da
habe ich auch nur gelacht aber da hat
sich jemand richtig mühe gegeben das
kunstvoll zu erkennen zu geben worum es
in wahrheit geht die beiden anderen male
waren bei einem noch viel größeren
sender und das sage ich jetzt nicht weil
ich den leuten mit denen ich da zu tun
hatte nicht schaden will die haben mir
auch hinweise gegeben wo ich einmal
ausgeladen worden bin und einmal etwas
was ich gesagt habe aus einem bestimmten
archiv verschwunden ist beziehungsweise
nicht eingewandert ist das ist schon auf
also es gibt kein sich schon aus seiner
sicht absolut bei den öffentlich
rechtlichen sendern wird werden die
geländer der meinungsfreiheit immer
näher heran gezogen an den pfad und
jetzt ist es unter anderem auch durch
die debatte über die sinnhaftigkeit des
impfens und von 2g an der zeit damit
schluss zu machen weil man wieder nimmt
sie das mal ganz kurz
gibt es die problematik dass in der
öffentlichkeit leute weil sie eine
andere meinung vertreten nicht mehr
eingeladen werden ich glaube auch dass
hierbei bild live schon mal leute nicht
mehr eingeladen worden weil
sie zu langweilig waren oder ihre
meinung vertreten haben wie sehr das
passt mir diese sendung also ich glaube
er ist es wichtig gerade übrigens im
öffentlichen recht im rundfunk dass wir
die vielfalt von meinungen präsentieren
ich finde das ist sehr sehr wichtig
glaube darum können uns alle einigen ich
glaube aber muss ebenso eine
unterscheidung machen zwischen was ist
meinung was ist was ist eine falsche
schatz an bord und ich glaube das ist
sehr wichtig dass wir gemeinsam auch
darüber sprechen ich kenne jetzt die
beiträge nicht über diese gesprochen
haben und ich kenne auch jetzt jeden
fall nicht im konkreten details so gut
wie sie in kärnten im fall hatte ich
noch keinen gegeben das aber da haben
die handballer ist ja aber ich glaube
schon dass ich so das entscheide ich
finde es gibt sehr viele menschen so
viele wie seit sehr langer zeit nicht
mehr die in deutschland sagen ich habe
das gefühl ich kann meine meinung nicht
mehr sagen und ich finde das ist ein
großes problem ich finde wir müssen
gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass das sich
dass die zahlen sich da deutlich
verringern auf der anderen seite wünsche
ich mir gerade von denen die sehr stark
mit ihrer meinung nach außen gehen und
so weiter dann auch einen gewissen
anzahl zu sagen ich halte auch dann
gegenmeinung aus ja ich mache da fragt
man nur einem satz wenn man das tut das
hier habe ich mehrfach grad ist ein
reich der freiheit hier darf jeder der
hier eingeladen wird seine meinung zu
sagen zu einem thema das er sich selber
aussucht aber wenn das so ist und wir
hier in verschiedener hinsicht völlig
frei reden brauchen wir auch verbündete
in der politik die das aufnehmen und
verteidigen und die kann ich momentan
nicht sehen was ist denn eine
verteidigerin der meinungsmache
herausgehalten sache aus sieben ja es
oft gar nicht ganz zum abschluss denn
dann müssen lang dem thema gehen was
verband man bewirkt zu machen braucht
mich hingeschmissen weil frau fans
beleidigt ist oder so sondern weil ich
unter den umständen mit der redaktion
aber weitere bild da möchte man immer
arbeitslos ist mein herr brand waren sie
haben für uns ein thema mitgebracht weil
für den a8 auf jeder sein thema ihr
thema mit brille ja ich habe mir lange
gedanken gemacht welches thema ist heute
mitbringen würde ich mich mit ihnen die
bei endometriose sprechen es ist eine
krankheit unter der über zwei millionen
frauen in deutschland gleich es geht
dabei um
wucherungen die etwa im bauchraum
auftreten und die dazu führen dass die
betroffenen wahnsinnige schmerzen haben
nicht nur wenn sie ihre regel haben
sondern auch teilweise im ganzen monat
die scheibe ins krankenhaus eingeliefert
werden müssen weil sie mit den ganzen
schmerz nämlich klar kommen die
wahnsinnige schmerzmittel zu sich nehmen
müssen und es gibt obwohl es zwei
millionen betroffene allein in
deutschland gibt es kaum forschung in
diesem bereich man will der französische
präsident hat eine nationale strategie
im kampf gegen endemische angekündigt in
frankreich ich finde dass deutschland
hier dringt nachziehen muss und ich
finde wir müssen als gesellschaft viel
stärker über dieses thema sprechen ich
würde sie auch vor meinem bekanntenkreis
bei den damen rom zu fragen wer alles in
den rücken indem er sie kennt ich glaube
es sind sehr viele und ich finde es
schade dass wir als gesellschaft und
übrigens auch als medien nicht genug
darüber sprechen und deshalb würde ich
ganz klar auch mal fragen warum
berichtet die bild zum beispiel nicht
darüber dass in wenigen tagen 70 70.000
unterschriften zusammengekommen sind in
einer petition für den kran obwohl man
sie sehen sie sitzen weil bild und wir
berichten darüber gerade in diesem
moment herrmann wie nehmen sie das wahr
als arzt wird so rüber da zu wenig
darüber gesprochen es gibt viele themen
in der medizin über die ganz wenig
berichtet werden es gibt immer die
highlights über die gerade mal
gesprochen wird und sicherlich ist die
endometriose euren thema wohl ganz wenig
schritt und gesprochen wird ich bin
sicherlich da auch nicht der spezialist
dafür als hausarzt ist das nicht mein
thema dafür gibt glücklicherweise also
dann die gynäkologen die sich damit
beschäftigen aber dass es generell ganz
viele themen gibt über die wenig
gesprochen wird und immer nur jetzt
gerade corinna als highlight
rausgenommen wird damit krone auch so
tun das andere krankheiten das über
andere krankheiten zu wenig gesprochen
wird es ist immer die frage ob es zu
wenig gesprochen wird oder ob sie zu
wenig im fokus der betrachtung stehen
und man muss sicherlich nicht über jede
krankheit in ihrer talkshow reden aber
man muss diese krankheiten ernst nehmen
und man muss sie auch im kampf
unterstützen das entsprechende
forschungsgelder da sind dass solche
dinge passieren dafür dass sie im
notorisch thema sind da passiert noch
nichts da verbessern wir noch keine
medizinische behandlung kommt ganz
schnell wie sehen sie das ja ich sollten
endlich gedanken sind wir uns völlig
einig welt alles was so krankheit die
unten rum sind bei frauen und so weiter
die betreffen männer wir haben eigene
sachen wird die krankheit werden man
scheut sich natürlich immer über so
etwas zu reden und deswegen ist das ein
wichtiger punkt deswegen habe ich eine
krone auf kuba jörges es gibt ja viele
dinge über die wir nicht mehr geredet
haben letzten zweieinhalb jahre ja das
stimmt erstens zweitens davon habe ich
noch nie gehört ich persönlich als man
bis ich wusste sie werden darüber reden
und ich habe festgestellt offensichtlich
weiß jede frau worum es da geht also
jeder einigermaßen gebildete erfahrene
frau weiß das und nun liebe frau
fdp-jugendorganisation
chefin das sage ich jetzt bewusst so die
forschungsministerin kommt aus ihrer
partei stark watzinger
der
gesundheitsminister kommt aus ihrer
koalition also muss ich diesem frank
bevor sie hier der zwang jetzt hat der
korona
raus mit der sprache das weiß ich nicht
ob er hat vielleicht eine psychische
erkrankung jedenfalls etwas
niedergeschlagen ist das jedenfalls
da sollten sie vor sprechen also die die
klagemauer ist nicht bild denn da sitzen
sie ja im moment sondern die klagemauer
müssen diejenigen die über fonds salatic
das ohne jorges bild zu verteidigen
herzlichen dank für diese wahnsinnig
spannende diskussion die wir heute
erlebt haben vielen vielen dank krieg
corona impfen meinungsfreiheit das war
für den r8 der talk der schlagzeilen
nach danke schön und schön ab
[Musik]